dr. Anthony failed she makes waves
before the Senate Los Angeles makes
moves to lockdown until well forever and
Democrats push a three trillion dollar
wish list i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show the ben shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn why haven't you
gotten a VPN yet visit expressvpn
dot-com / Ben all right so dr. Anthony
factory went before the Senate yesterday
and this caused all sorts of controversy
you know frankly I'm sort of perturbed
at the controversy the reason being I
don't think the foul Qi is a bad guy I
don't think that foul Qi is out to ruin
the American economy I don't think that
he is a malign influence on President
Trump I think that doctor foul Qi is an
epidemiologist and his job is to be an
epidemiologist his job is to be a doctor
of Public Health when it comes to
pandemics his job is not to balance all
of the risks and rewards when you go to
a doctor and you look for a diagnosis
usually the doctor puts before you a
fair number of choices and it is now
your determination as to which choice
you seek right the doctor puts before it
you have cancer god forbid and the
doctor says to you okay so here are the
choices you could have a surgery here
are the risks and then the possibilities
you can have chemotherapy here are the
risks and the possibilities or depending
on your age may be the best thing is to
sort of let it take its course if you're
85 years old and you have prostate
cancer maybe the treatment is actually
worse than the disease and now you have
a bunch of choices in front of you it is
not the doctor's job to make the final
determination when it comes to public
policy making our elected officials are
elected to make exactly these
determinations why well because they're
answerable to we they are answerable to
us their answer once we the people the
fact that we are now looking to sort of
delegate all decision-making authority
to the experts is the is the tail end of
the Progressive Era stupidity that
suggested that if we just gave all power
to the quote-unquote experts in
governments then everything would
magically be solved now experts are good
for what experts are good for experts
are good for knowing a lot of things
about one particular subject but they're
not famous for knowing lots of things
about lots of particular subjects if you
ask doctor foul at you about Keynesian
versus Milton Friedman Eska economics my
guess is that he wouldn't know much more
than the average guy but if you ask him
about disease vectors and he probably
knows a lot more than the average guy
asking him to be the sole policy maker
is really
Hardy and even doctor foul she knows
this and so these sort of move from the
left to a point doctor foul chew the
head of government when he is not the
head of government or to use him as a
club to wield against elected officials
whom again our answer all of whom are
answerable toss right that the fact that
people in left wanna do that and then
the fact that the people on the right
are responding to that by blending
pouches the foul Qi is to blame for
lawmakers abdicating their duty and just
pointing to foul England well he's gonna
solve all of our problems
it's stupidity I mean frankly I think
that doctor foul shoe would be the first
person to say that it's stupidity he is
there to provide medical knowledge and
guidance and then it is up to us to
determine what risks we are willing to
undertake as a society what this means
that when people like doctor foul at you
when public health experts testify
publicly they are always going to
testify on behalf of caution because
their job is first you know harm on a
public health level not an economic
level not on the freedom level not on a
constitutional level not in a
governmental level their first job is to
say how do we save the most lives well
in the middle of pandemic the easy
answer if you're not looking at any of
the other factors is stay home until we
have some sort of therapeutic or until
we have some sort of vaccine but of
course there are other factors to take
into account when it comes to public
policy making such as the fact that we
may never have vaccine or therapeutic
may not be all that effective and the
fact that thirty million people have
lost their jobs in the last six weeks
and that there are countervailing costs
to people losing their jobs losing their
livelihoods a hundred thousand small
businesses shutting down this is where
it is up to our public of our public
officials the people who we actually
elect our elected officials to weigh the
evidence the doctor foul is providing in
his advice but the evidence provided by
economists with the values that we hold
dear as a nation I mean just take take a
different example for a second in a
wartime let's say that you were to ask a
public health expert in more time what
is the best policy well public health
experts job is to save as many lives as
possible so the public health expert
would say best strategy here is probably
not to do the war right no war is good
because that means few people are gonna
get shot and killed but if you are an
elected official and it's World War two
you know that there gonna be a certain
number of people we're gonna have to
risk their lives on the beaches of
Normandy this is not to suggest that the
public health experts are wrong about
everything this is to suggest that
everybody has their own specific area of
expertise and to pretend that this means
a broad area of expertise is really
foolish and in a republic we rely on the
notion that a diffuse level a value
judgment
among the American population is gonna
be better than anyone individuals values
that the American people overall are
going to be wiser about weighing all of
these factors in balance when they elect
people then just one guy who's part of
the bureaucracy well get to what dr.
factory had to say yesterday because it
in that light I don't think what he had
to say was all that controversial but I
think they're politicians who are
completely looking to abdicate
responsibility for their actual
decision-making role in American
politics right now and simply shouting
data and science and public health
official look what Foundry is saying
look what look what Burks is saying look
what all the scientists are saying okay
that's not your only job you're supposed
to take all that into consideration and
then you are supposed to weigh all of
the values that are currently under
consideration plus you're supposed to
determine the level of certainty that
public health officials are expressing
about the pewte of the future about the
future generally because experts may be
more expert than you but that does not
mean that they have 100% certain
knowledge of the future it will get to
all of that in just one second first I
don't tell you about this thing that I
just did for my kids it is like the best
thing I've done for my kids
this entire lockdown time it's just
fantastic I'm talking about literati
literati is a subscription book club
makes it easy to find unique
thought-provoking books for your kids
delivering great stories straight to
your doorstep so my kids are big into
reading I love reading to them and
literati will send you a box that is
filled with fantastic books and
activities for your kids they sent my
daughter a pair of butterfly wings that
she will not stop wearing around the
house they sent these secret pens these
fantastic markers that are like
invisible ink and you're trying to light
a UV light on them and they light up my
kids are just thrilled with this my
four-year-old boy and my six-year-old
girl and they tailor each of these to
the age and the and the the kind of
interest of your children it's just
fantastic
each literary literati box contains five
beautiful books based on a theme and
contains exclusive original art and a
personalized notes to your child
literati will actively curate stories
that spark curiosity and promote
independent thinking saving you hours of
searching the store or scrolling through
lists of mediocre books online and
literati will beat the amazon list price
so you are saving money as well you only
keep your favorites and then you send
the rest back for free so it's like half
library half book buying Enterprise is
just fantastic but the schools and
libraries closed literati is working to
get books in the hands of families don't
have access to educational materials of
your own you can reuse the literati box
to donate alcohol outgrown books
and literati will match every single one
that you sent for a limited time go to
literati comm slash up hero for 25
percent off your first two orders this
is their best offer available anywhere
to get it you have to go to literati
comm slash up hero you get 25 percent
off your first two orders literati comm
slash but that's a great deal let me
tell you my kids are they love it like I
don't know who's selecting the books
over there but they are doing an amazing
job and my kids favorite books are
coming through literati calm and go to
literati calm slash shapiro and get 25%
off your first order seriously i can't
overstate how awesome this service is
okay so dr. Falchi before the senate
yesterday so he's testifying and again
dr. pouch is only gonna get blamed if
there excess deaths this is the other
thing you have to understand about job
description if your job description is
you're a doctor and somebody comes in
and they're looking for a cancer
screening you're only gonna get sued for
malpractice if you miss the cancer
you're not gonna get sued for
malpractice if you do too many tests if
you run too many tests you're not gonna
get sued for malpractice if you miss the
cancer in the person dies you're gonna
get sued for malpractice okay so now
take that to epidemiology if you are dr.
fowey and you recommend a full-scale
lockdown forever you're never gonna get
blamed for excess deaths because first
of all that's never going to happen and
you recommend it against it and number
two that is the junior harm principle on
a medical front hey you are gonna get
blamed if you're like you know what
everything is basically okay if you're
young then first of all everything is
not basically okay but if you are young
then you are very unlikely to get a
serious case of this disease and you are
extraordinarily unlikely to die if you
are older then you should probably
shelter in place if out you were to say
something like that and be clear about
the actual chances of something terrible
happening to you based on age and based
on pre-existing condition like it's
amazing to me that we are now how many
months into this thing and we still
cannot get straight answers from our
public officials about what are your
chances if you're 20 years old and
healthy of dying of Kovan 19 hey I'll
give you the answer the answer is you
have got a 2 in 10,000 chance of dying
of covered 19 according to the antibody
tests right that that is not a high
chance one in 5,000 is not a high chance
it is a chance that you are willing to
take to go back to work and enjoy your
life obviously but if you are an
epidemiologist you only get blamed if
you say that things aren't you know
basically okay for particular sectors of
the population and then there's an
unexpected outbreak and you get blamed
for that you never get blamed in the
field of Epidemiology and prediction
science for being overly pessimistic you
only get blamed for being overly
optimistic every time there's a massive
economic
down term everybody who said oh the tail
was headed for 35,000 all those people I
got ya idiot
Dallas headed for 35,000 ya and
the person who was like well I told you
there was going to be doom and then that
one time there was Duma car I told you
there was gonna be doom all you have to
do if you are a pessimist in the field
of public health or predictions or any
of the sort of stuff is to be right once
you know for me right 10,000 times just
be right once if you're an optimist you
have to be right every single time
because the one time that you are wrong
everybody is going to say to you well if
it weren't for you and your optimism
then there would be this many people
alive wouldn't there and it doesn't
matter that the optimistic take is right
nine times out of ten we're only going
to blame you for the downside risks so
foul she knows that too so here is dr.
fad yesterday before the Senate and he
says that the u.s. death rate is
unacceptable compared to other countries
now again the way that he's phrasing
this is kind of silly the reality is
that every death is quote unquote
unacceptable is anybody like happy with
the levels of death in the United States
but compared to other industrialized
countries the United States is actually
not doing particularly poorly we're
right in the middle of the pack when it
comes to Europe we are if you take New
York out of out of the calculations and
New York was obviously the hardest hit
and it's Orton outlier in terms of
population density if you take New York
out of the picture of the United States
ranks kind of near Germany that closer
to Germany in terms of death per million
population
here's that graph out you those saying
that the u.s. death rate is unacceptable
compared to other countries the devil in
the United States the death rate in the
United States especially when compared
with other nations is unacceptable isn't
it
yes of course I mean a death rate that
high is something that in any matter of
form in my mind is unacceptable and dr.
grouchy the experienced above the nation
shows that the u.s. separate is not only
unacceptable but it's unnecessary isn't
a correct I don't I don't know if we can
say that said that but would you say
that the US has to do matter of course
you always have to do better okay this
is idiotic remember senator Tim Kaine
who is Hillary Clinton's vice
presidential candidate now he's a
professional stagecoach robber he said
that's exciting stuff for folks you
can't see he's weren't a bandana around
his neck directly from assassination of
Jesse James by the Coward Robert Ford
2007 good movie but the notion that we
could do better I mean we can always do
better sure we can always do better but
that's an obvious gotcha
by Kane and Falchi is being
fairly circumspect in the way that he's
phrasing this stuff because again his
job is to be an epidemiologist not to be
a policymaker
so fat she also says there could be
consequences if we reopen too quickly
now of course that's true
it is also true that he's only gonna get
blamed if we were open too quickly
meaning what do you think he's gonna say
guys go out willy nilly have at it he's
of course not gonna say that if he says
you know we set some standards for being
careful and if we hold to those
standards then I think that we will
suffer less death than if we don't hold
it like what do you expect him to say
the CDC set particular standards I think
those standards are probably overly
restrictive but found she'd things not
and of course he's gonna defend his
standards it'd be silly of him not to
see her spout yesterday the consequences
could be really uh serious particularly
and this is something that I think we
also should pay attention to that states
even if they're doing it at an
appropriate pace which many of them are
and will namely a pace that's
commensurate with the dynamics of the
outbreak that they have in place already
the capability that when there will be
cases there is no doubt even under the
best of circumstances when you pull back
on mitigation you will see some cases
appear okay and that's true okay so he's
not really giving you any information
you didn't know in other words the more
you walk down the fewer people are gonna
be infected yeah we knew that but he's
not actually setting a standard as to
what he thinks is a safe level of
infection because the truth is it's how
she doesn't know the answer to that what
foul she knows is that if you let people
out of lockdown then more people will be
infected more people will die but we're
going to have to let people out of
lockdown
everyone recognizes this and you know
who is best situated to make these
decisions individual governors court
answerable to people because the fact is
voters are gonna have to decide whether
they think their governors did a good
job in protecting them and also
protecting the economy by the way worth
noting Brian Kemp right the governor of
Georgia who's been ripped up and down
the infection rates in his state are not
spiking yet they are not Rhonda census
in Florida
the massive overwhelming infections that
were supposed to happen they have not
been happening in Florida Texas no
overwhelming infection rates in Texas in
fact it seems like things are kind of
spiking faster in California than they
are in some of these other states in
California is still in full-scale
lockdown a Rand Paul makes this point
yesterday and he's ripped up and down by
left for making it but Rand Paul says I
don't think that you're the be-all
end-all now the only part about this
that I objected seriously is I'm not
sure that vouchered thinks he's the
be-all end-all in fact how she sort of
admits it right so Rand Paul says listen
I don't think that you're the
decision-maker I think we're the
decision-maker and here you're here to
provide information Rand Paul by the way
is a medical doctor so here's Rand Paul
he doesn't have to wear the mask because
obviously he's already had Cove in 19 so
he can walk around like he's bulletproof
at this point
here's Senator Rand Paul growing a
pandemic beard as well every everybody
is one thing that I'm enjoying about
this is apparently everybody is now
going to dress and grow facial hair like
we are in the immediate aftermath of the
civil war which I mean honestly kinda
cool like I could go I want to see some
handlebar moustaches I want to see some
Ambrose Burnside's sideburns I want to
see like like the like let's go full out
at this point my bandanas hats I didn't
do it anyway her Senator Paul as much as
I respect to dr. falchi I don't think
you're the end-all I don't think you're
the one person that gets to make a
decision we can listen to your advice
but there are people on the other side
saying there's not going to be a serves
and then we can safely open the economy
and the facts will to bear this out but
if we keep kids out of school for
another year what's gonna happen is that
the poor are gonna prove these kids you
don't have a parent that they were to
teach them at home are not gonna learn
for a full year
Senator Paul thank you for your comments
I have never made myself out to be the
end-all and only voice in this I'm a
scientist a physician and a public
health official I give advice according
to the best scientific evidence there
are a number of other people who come
into that and give advice that are more
related to the things that you spoke
about about the need to get the country
back open again and economically I don't
give advice about economic things I
don't get advice about anything other
than public help correct correct a case
of foul cheese acknowledging the truth
here so every was taking it as though
Paul and found you really going out of
here they're on the same team here I
mean everyone should be on the same team
which is we have to take the advice and
then we have to calculate that and in
whatever formula we're using for when
reopening is good and possible and as
Rand Paul points out you know the level
of certainty that experts have had in
making predictions has been off pretty
much every step of the way sometimes too
high sometimes too low as more data
comes in hopefully the predictions get
better and we also have to kind of
decide which experts know best because
experts do conflict with each other
fairly wildly is I'm gonna talk about in
just a moment I mean in fact it turns
out a lot of the models originally we're
quite wrong it also turns out a lot of
the public health officials don't know
crap about stuff I mean like I think
vouch actually knows some things I just
tell you the public health officials in
California they don't know a damn thing
I mean seriously the policies that they
are trotting out at this point are some
of the dumbest policies I've ever seen
and they frankly have no qualifications
to make these policies like Syria like
they don't even have the qualifications
of about a foul Qi or a Burks in terms
of like an actual medical degree it's
make these sort of qualifications here
is Rand Paul I think the one size fits
all that we're gonna have a national
strategy nobody's gonna go to school is
kind of ridiculous we really ought to be
doing in school district by school
district and that the power needs to be
dispersed because people make wrong
predictions and really the history of
this when we look back will be a wrong
prediction after wrong prediction after
wrong prediction starting with Ferguson
in England so I think we ought to have a
little bit of humility in our belief
that we know what's best for the economy
okay that of course is exactly right
it's exactly right in just a second I'm
gonna explain to you how many of the
models pretty much all the models got
the Swedish death rates wrong so Sweden
has been sort of the whipping post for a
lot of the Democrat and and left-leaning
views of lockdown Sweden's terrible
Sweden's horrible they've a higher death
rate per million than we do if they lock
down their nursing homes which is
something they acknowledge they should
have done Sweden would be in the best
shape of anybody and it would not really
be close because there's not gonna be a
second wave in Sweden they're not
changing their policy and dr. Thatcher
you said yesterday there will be a
second wave in the United States yeah I
would assume there would be and we'll
get to that in just one second first let
us talk about the fact that this is a
really really rough time in the American
economy that means that with precision
if you're an employer you need to be
finding the best employees and if you're
an employee you need to be getting those
job listings in your inbox like ASAP as
soon as those things hit the internet I
have a magic solution for you it's
called Zippo query you know the zipper
career is doing great work every day to
hook up employers with prospective
employees and prospective employees with
prospective employers zip recruiter is
dedicated to helping you get hired
whether you're looking for jobs in
caretaking delivering food and goods to
building medical facilities supplying
protective equipment and so much more
and as we reopen the economy there are
going to be businesses that are looking
to staff up and higher up that is
particularly true because of the foolish
congressional bills that have been
passed that disincentivize work for a
certain sector of the
population zip recruiter is gonna help
you find a job if you're looking for a
job and they're gonna help you find
great employees if you're looking for
great employees zip recruit will invite
candidates to apply to your most urgent
roles making it faster and easier to
reach the people you need by connecting
people who need jobs and companies that
need people zip recruiter is working
with all of us so we can keep moving
forward as a country let's all work
together zip recruit comm / work
together that zip recruiter comm / work
together the great service in normal
times in non normal times they are just
indispensable zip recruiter comm / work
together
ok so speaking of the models and the
experts when we talk about expertise we
have to determine what exactly is the
level of expertise of which we are
speaking so there's a good piece in The
Spectator the UK Spectator by Johan
Norberg and he writes about the modeling
with regard to Sweden he says maria
gunther and maria west home in dagens
nyheter
Sweden's biggest daily just took a look
at two of the most influential models in
Sweden both were inspired by the
Imperial College study and published on
the preprint server met our R X IV in
April both were used by critics to argue
the Swedish model would quickly break
our health care system and then we had
to make a u-turn into lockdown as
Britain did hear what the models
predicted there was one by a guy named
Odin that said that the critical care
demand would peak above sixteen thousand
patients per day by early May and
pre-pandemic intensive care unit
capacity would be exceeded by a factor
of 30 and there was a second study that
was even more pessimistic showing a peak
of over 20,000 patients by early May
with in ICU requirement about 40 times
at the actual capacity
Sweden's Public Health Agency rejected
the models and instead planned for a
worst-case scenario that was much less
pessimistic suggesting a peak around
1,700 ICU patients in the middle of May
there's still more than three times the
pre-pandemic capacity sweden refused to
lock down the results or that the number
of ICU patients was about 500 to 550
since mid-april capacity was never
exceeded in fact it wasn't exceeded by a
factor of three at this moment when the
model suggested Sweden would have 30 to
40 patients fighting over every
available ICU bed there are spare
capacity in beds equipment in personnel
of around 30 percent one of those models
predicted that Sweden would have 82,000
Cova 19 deaths by the 1st of July or a
thousand deaths every day since the
paper was published in mid April a total
number of coconuts at the time of
writing is 3313 one reason the models
failed is that they underestimated how
millions of people spontaneously adapt
to new circumstances and this really
is the key the fact is that Americans
are adapting to this stuff there's a new
study out today showing the 25 million
more Americans are moving around freely
right they're going around and they are
they are driving around by data they're
not staying at home but that doesn't
mean they're not taking precautions
again I've been out and about in Los
Angeles with my kids we're going to
parks we've gone to a beach okay the
fact is that people are social
distancing people are being careful in
how they approach this sort of stuff
people are not stupid people don't want
to die
now there are some people who are just
going to shake their fist at the moon
and be like you know I'm gonna go make
out with a stranger at a restaurant most
people are not doing that the vast
majority of people are not doing that
and that means that all of the
predictions about mass carnage are
probably wrong they're probably off
fairly substantially it is also
necessary to point out the people who
are being pushed forward as experts in
many cases policy makers and quote
unquote experts are not in fact experts
okay so for example in LA there's a
woman named dr. Barbara Ferrer she's the
LA County Department of Public Health
right she runs the LA Department the
County Department Public Health LA
County just announced that they were
going to lock down until the beginning
of August yeah as in like I know I
checked the calendar too yesterday when
I found out about this it was May 12th
yesterday for those who missed it okay
so that means that they are there now
locking down two and a half months in
advance which let's be real about this
the actual the actual intent here has
nothing to do with lockdown everybody
understands people are gonna go back to
work before that everyone understands
that what's actually happening here is
that the County of Los Angeles is trying
to create a legal excuse or telling
people they don't have to pay their rent
that's really what's actually going on
here what they want to say to people in
LA is sure we're in lockdown and because
we're in lockdown and I'm putting
lockdown in air quotes for those who
can't say we're in lockdown which
doesn't mean you can't go to work
it just means you don't have to pay your
rent that's what LA County is attempting
to do we're gonna jack landlords is
basically the idea here it makes sense
on a mortgage level because you can add
months to the back of the mortgage right
what doesn't make a whole hell of a lot
of sense he's doing that with regard to
rent let's say you have a one-year lease
and then the LA County Board of
Supervisors and the Public Health
Department decide that because of
lockdown you don't have to pay your rent
while we're in the middle of lockdown
it's a one-year lease let's say that
that one your lease expires at the end
of the lockdown is that is the landlord
gonna receive back rent or is the
landlord just gonna be out a year of
rent
I mean it's fairly obvious what exactly
is happening here there's a reason that
landlords I mean I know landlords in LA
they're already saying okay I want to
sell my building get the hell out of
here
there's gonna be such epic flight from
Los Angeles after this is over it's
gonna be incredible
people are gonna move from New York
people gonna move from LA they're gonna
move to other states the population
movement in the aftermath of this
pandemic based on local governance is
gonna be absolutely astonishing that is
my prediction but speaking of dr.
Barbara Ferrer let me talk about her
qualifications for a second so why
exactly she the head of public health in
LA County what her hurt what are her
bona fide he's well she was executive
director of the Boston Public Health
Commission where she led a range of
public health programs and builds
innovative partnerships to address
inequities in health outcomes and
support healthy communities and healthy
families she secured federal state and
local funding for critical public health
infrastructure and community-based
programs okay so what exactly is her
background in science well she's a PhD
in social walther from Brandeis she has
a Master of Arts in public health Master
of Arts not not master of Sciences
Master of Arts in public health from
Boston University a Master of Arts in
education from University of
Massachusetts Boston a Bachelor of Arts
in community studies from UC Santa Cruz
so in other words like what is the
evidence that this person is
scientifically knowledgeable in any
actual way III do not know yet this is
the person who is tasked with leading up
the experts in LA County
by the way CNN is promoting its own
batch of experts who are the experts
that CNN is promoting they're they're
having a new town hall and one of their
one of their astonishingly great town
halls who are they actually hosting well
they're having on former acting CDC
director Richard Besser fine the former
HHS Secretary Kathleen Sebelius fine dr.
Sanjay Gupta and Greta thundered weird a
fun bird like the 17 year old whose main
accomplishment is in life is going
around and screaming at adults about how
angry she is that's literally like she's
an expert on yelling at adults listen to
the experts guys especially small
children who are screaming at you about
how we need to destroy the inside like
first of all I think like in terms of
the economic impact of all of this let's
be real the green New Deal that she has
proposed is exactly what is happening
right now so if you're enjoying what's
going on right now then you know if you
want more of that talk to Greta Thun
berg because that what that's what you'd
like to see in perpetuity in terms of
economic activity but how it like she's
being trotted forth as an expert CNN the
most trusted name in news trust the
experts guy
trust the experts we'll get to the trust
the experts attitude in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that now
is like the worst time in history to go
to the post office but what if you need
to send packages what if you're still
running a business what if you need to
send mail to your friends and family
well stamps comm is here to help with
Sam's comm you can print postage on
demand skip those lines and crowds at
the post office plus you can actually
save some money with discounts you can't
even get at the post office as if that
wasn't enough stamps comm also offers
UPS services with discounts up to 62
percent and no UPS residential
surcharges we've been using stamps
daikon since 2017 here at the Daily wire
it is a godsend it saves us tons of time
and tons of money
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service directly to your
computer in the safety and comfort of
your own home office or anywhere else
you're hunkering down right now whether
you're a small business sending invoices
or an online sellers shipping out
products whether you're working from
home and you just need a mail stuff
stamps calm is the answer for you right
now my listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and digital scale no long
term commitment just go to stamps com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page type in Shapiro that is
stamps comm type in Shapiro you get that
amazing special offer and again you
don't wanna go to the post office anyway
now you save all sorts of cost and time
and money for WIC trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long-term
commitment stamps comm click on the Mike
at the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro okay so our health experts here
in LA County dr. Barbara Ferrer and I
guess the CNN's appointed health expert
Greta Thunderbird who again when I think
who would I go to in terms of handling a
pandemic
I think seventeen-year-old Swedish child
who screams at adults to the applause of
the media that bad that's why that's who
I would go to and honestly if that's who
I usually go to when I'm when I am
looking for good advice on serious
issues I immediately go to my own
children who are excellent - screaming
adults it turns out they are great at it
I have a six-year-old daughter she's
fantastic at screaming at me and tells
my four-year-old son and when I want
policy advice I just I go right to them
and then I let them scream in my face
for a while and then I'm like oh problem
solved done maybe they should be on CNN
as public health experts they know as
much about pandemics is as Greta Thun
burg come the hell on CNN and then you
expect me to take seriously uh listen to
the experts we here at CNN we listen to
the experts Chris Cuomo yesterday was
doing
routine right Chris Cuomo who listens to
the experts so much that he was
violating his his own quarantine while
he had covered 19 and was meanwhile
asking sick of handset questions to his
big brother Andrew who is the worst
governor in America by numbers I'm Kovac
19 here is CNN's Chris Cuomo yesterday
being like you know what we have to
listen to the we have to listen to the
experts guys listen to the experts
everybody I'm agog yesterday how can we
beat the virus if we can't even get on
the same page about how important the
fight is if we can't even agree on what
it takes to win let's bring in dr.
Sanjay Gupta and Andy Slavitt
first just a slap in the face of reality
for us fellas Sanjay ten thousand deaths
as the approximated cost of reopening as
of now have you ever seen America make a
choice like this before what hell is he
talking about America makes choices
every day that increased risk to its
citizens because that's called freedom
seriously like no one's talking about
going to nursing homes and snuffing out
grandma everybody here is talking about
how you mitigate risk while also
allowing tens of millions of people to
go back to work and get jobs again and
function in an economy this is the sort
of disgusting dump it really is
discussing this sort of disgusting
demagoguery from have you ever seen
Americans willing to sacrifice ten
thousand lives for what something like
freedom something like being able to
work or a functioning economy I mean
actually fairly regularly that's called
public policy that's called public
policy it's not about sacrificing lives
right that is a framing of the question
that is so deeply dishonest but I'm sure
he can get buy-in from Greta Sundberg
over at CNN ok so this sort of idiocy
leads to the kind of policies that we
have seen in the state of California my
home state so the state of California
has not suffered from a massive outbreak
the state of California has last I
checked something like seven deaths per
100,000 citizens in the state of
California grand total in in the state
of California California Cova 19 deaths
last I checked were under 3,000 deaths
statewide we have 40 million citizens in
the state of California we have 2770
confirmed us from Cove in nineteen in
the state of California according to
sort of the numbers that Google is
popping up for me here right now
okay so
those are not massive incredibly large
numbers and though those are every death
is a tragedy every death is bad but
California is not the center of this
outbreak I guess it's up to 2880 to
according to the LA Times okay that
that's that's terrible it's bad and we
should be careful when we reopen but the
state of California has basically
decided that we are now engaged in a in
a kindergarten game of one-upsmanship
and it was pretty obvious that this is
how things were gonna go when the
lockdowns originally occurred right San
Francisco lockdown and then immediately
thereafter la walk down and then
immediately thereafter New York lockdown
and so it's gonna be the other way
around right you're seeing one game of
follow-the-leader when it comes to
reopening with some state saying listen
we gotta reopen or our economy's gonna
die
other states are saying listen we're not
gonna be blamed right if you're gavin
newsom if you want to avoid scrutiny
what you say at this point is we're
never gonna reopen ever right we're not
reopening until there's a vaccine if
you're JB Pritzker know Illinois
we're not reopening until there's a
vaccine because I'm not gonna be blamed
for 1xs death I'm not gonna be blamed
for any sort of excess death now here's
the reality politicians cannot walk down
this way Americans are just not going to
stand for it and they're particularly
not gonna lock down in the idiotic
fashion that is now being promoted by
you Los Angeles state government so
California is saying well why don't we
let people decide on a county-by-county
basis just gonna point out when Donald
Trump says that according to the states
when he says states should decide
vocalism should rule he's very bad when
Gavin Newsom says County should decide
on a county-by-county basis then Gavin
Newsome apparently according to the
media is very very good but according to
county public health director Barbara
Ferrer she said at Tuesday's Board of
Supervisors meeting based on her
community relations degree from UC Santa
Cruz based on all the data we're looking
at we know what certainty will be
extending health off officer orders for
the next three months three months the
stay-at-home restrictions orders will be
in place for three months how do you
even know that how can you we couldn't
forecast this thing two weeks out Ferrer
said well the safer at home orders will
remain in place over the next few months
restrictions will be gradually relaxed
under the county's existing roadmap to
recovery we're counting on the public's
continued compliance with the orders to
enable us to relax restrictions they say
that instead the LA County Board of
Supervisors is trying to claim that they
were that they were taken out of context
because the original statement is that
the stand
would remain in place as his for three
months Mayor Eric Garcetti said I think
quite simply she's saying we're not
gonna fully reopen Los Angeles and
probably anywhere in America without any
protections or any health orders in the
next three months I think it's gonna be
even longer than three months okay
that's not what the original statement
was the original statement was the
stay-at-home orders are gonna remain in
place for three months until the end of
July which is patently insane it means
the end of the economy of Los Angeles
has everybody well understands and as it
turns out the policies that are being
promulgated in LA are completely idiotic
so are the policies in California for
reopening counties I'll explain the
policies okay here are some of the
policies the policies according to the
LA Times at the beaches you ready for
this how people can use the sand will
look different face coverings will be
required when not in the water
sunbathing won't be allowed only active
recreation surfing running walking and
swimming will be permitted coolers
chairs umbrellas and any of the other
accessories that typically dot the
shoreline should be left at home do
people understand like why masks are
useful or why being outside is good or
why social distancing is useful so the
idea is what I'm gonna like take my kids
to the beach I'm gonna pop open that
back door I'm gonna take my kids I'm
going to walk down with them to the
water throw them in the water take them
out of the water walk back to the car
and shove them inside like what the hell
are you talking about it's not how
beaches work what are you talking about
and if I'm if I've got a 20 foot radius
around me I'm sitting there on the sand
explain to me how that's a bad thing
explain explain me why I need to wear a
face mask when I'm socially distancing
from other people there's literally no
reason I don't need to wear a face mask
if I am outside in the Sun the Sun by
the way which does kill the virus
according to best available evidence and
I'm 10 feet away from everybody else
like this is madness but that's not the
that's not even the extent of the
stupidity so according to gavin newsom
standards there are two criteria as to
which counties can move into reopening
phases whether deaths have stopped
completely in the last 14 days from
cover 19 and whether there is no more
than one case per 10,000 residents in
that same time period most of California
failed that test in fact 95 percent of
Californians live in counties that don't
meet that standard
The Times analysis found not a single
County in Southern California nor the
San Francisco Bay Area met the criteria
deaths have stopped for 14 days
deaths have stopped for 14 days okay let
me let me just ask a quick question um
has anybody in
has there been any any place in
California like LA County let's take LA
County
what LA County have to shut down for the
actual flu okay this is more dangerous
than the flu this is always my
stipulation because people in the media
get very uptight when you mentioned the
flu in the same sentence as kovat so let
it be known kovat is more dangerous than
the flu and more transmissible but I'm
pointing out that we are not shutting
down for the flu in LA County there has
not been a week in California for six
years where somebody did not die of the
flu
here is a chart provided to you by LA
County which shows that it turns out
people died of the flu every single week
every week from 2014 to present right
this is pneumonia and influenza as a
percent of all deaths LA County 2013 in
2014 to 2019 2020 so what the hell are
you talking about there won't be a death
for 48 you know many people live in LA
County there are 10 million people in LA
County so you're telling me that until
there's not one Cove in 19 death in all
of LA County so I guess like in a
hundred years when several generations
of Los Angelenos have died then I guess
we can reopen according to these
standards this is just madness it's
complete and utter insanity meanwhile
California State University is gonna
teach remotely in the fall they're not
gonna let the students go back to school
why well they can't explain it because
the reality is that young people are not
in particularly terrible shape in fact
young people are in particularly good
shape if you're vulnerable you should
stay off campus and mitch Daniels who's
the president / / dude the Dean / Perdue
he said we're gonna reopen and we're
going to take precautions for people who
are vulnerable this would be the
rational solution but we cannot pursue
rationality and in any way it's locked
down infinity locked out and then locked
down infinity plus one that's the way
this is gonna work for a lot of
politicians when the media set up a
standard such that reopening is
considered you green-lighting death it
is not a shock that politicians respond
to that political incentive by saying
okay let's lock down forever and as we
will see that's exactly what Joe Biden
is doing who again is like the man is
barely alive at this point we'll get to
that in just one moment first it has
never been more important to manage your
business at workforce and work flow
really well systems are super crucial
right now the Benham brothers are
excellent at this these guys have over a
dozen businesses including a real estate
empire that spans 35 states just a few
the Benham brothers launched a new
podcast it's called expert ownership in
that new podcast the Benham brothers
interview leaders from all walks of life
to help you navigate your business
through these really challenging times
you're gonna hear from leaders like
Senator Ted Cruz L Robertson from duck
dynasty and many more now I know the
venom brothers really good dudes really
excellent Family Values guys go check
out their new podcast expert ownership
and be sure to subscribe on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen we will
drop a link to their podcast in the show
description again that's expert
ownership go check it out right now like
if you're looking for some business
expertise talk to the venom brothers
there's a reason they're really really
good at what they do and again these are
guys who stood up for their values so
much that they were basically booted off
TV for being Christian go check out the
venom brothers right now for a dose of
values and a dose of business sense go
check out their brand new podcast expert
ownership and check it out at Apple
podcast okay in just a second we're
gonna be getting to the the political
incentive to never open up ever ever
again and how Democrats are taking
advantage of this to attempt to cram
down trillions in new spending on
garbage that they have always sought
we'll get to that momentarily first I
want to take a moment to tell you about
the Daily wires newest most exclusive
membership tier all access the all
access membership tier is our premier
level of membership all access members
get to participate in all access live
that's our brand new interactive
programming programming featuring one of
us daily wire host as we hang out with
you each night at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m.
Pacific Andrew Clavin will be hosting
you tonight so get excited drew is the
person who I think it is fair to say is
is probably you're gonna over the next
ten years are gonna get the least of
drew of the most of us so he's in short
supply go check him out tonight over at
daily wire 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
also you get benefits of our other
membership tiers including the a free
website experience access to our live
broadcast and show library access to the
mailbags the full three hours of the Ben
Shapiro show get dedicated editorials
from me well access membership also
includes the singular irreplaceable
leftist cheers tumbler head on over
daily wire.com slash subscribe join our
all-access Club with new membership or
an upgrade you get 10% off with coupon
code Shapiro that's daily wire.com slash
subscribe see you there you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so the the Democrats are
naturally glomming onto the media the
media calculus here the Democrats
continue to push lockdowns that move
beyond the possibility of any sort of
real calibrated response it's not as
what they've set a timeline that's in
any way realistic and that LA County
timeline is insane 14 days with no
deaths from Kobe 19 how about 14 days
with no deaths from a car accident
before we can get back on the roads like
this is that's not it's just nuts okay
but you have Eric Garcetti saying
Americans want us to get it right yes we
do you know what getting it right looks
like allowing people back like there
will not be a functioning economy in the
city of Los Angeles and if you think
that all you're gonna do is just tax the
rich people in LA I guess what rich
people have the capacity to do move to
leave they're the only people in LA you
have the capacity to leave
hey here's mayor Garcetti most Americans
want us to get it right you look at
polls across the country certainly here
in Los Angeles it goes slow don't go
fast and get it right so we don't have
to retreat so she wanted to make sure
that I communicated and what she was
communicating is that we still need to
have a public health order because there
are some populations who will need to
stay at home people need to know
whenever possible it is safer to stay at
home so if you can telecommute etcetera
and there's no radical changes in the
next week coming ok so again when he
says that people wants you to go slow
nobody is defining these terms go slow
nobody's defining what exactly that
looks like all the polls are
extraordinarily vague about which exact
policies people approve of people are
basically on board with them asking
people are basically on board with the
social distancing but very few people
are on board with you let's just stay in
lockdown until the end of time and yet
that's exactly what you're getting from
Joe Biden again it's very easy to sit
outside the decision-making process like
Joe Biden is in his basement and and
basically suggest okay we don't have to
make any tough decisions here it's an
easy decision just lock down forever
this is particularly true when your end
goal for American government is the
radical growth of American government
Universal basic income the government
paying people to stay home which is
exactly what Democrats are proposing
here was Joe Biden yesterday saying he's
frustrated that people are trying to
open the economy and I'm frustrated at
the fact that Joe Biden
is utterly incompetent and has no actual
advice to offer it's amazing he keeps
writing editorials talking about how
seriously he takes this and then he
offers no actual
I reject the premise that somehow this
is hurting us there's no evidence of
that I'm following the rules following
the rules the president should follow
the rules instead of showing up a places
without masks in the whole the whole
thing look this is I'm getting really
frustrated with not you with this the
whole notion that somehow there is we
can just open we can move okay well like
what no-one's talking about completely
reopening at this point literally not
one state in America what the hell is he
talking about by setting up this false
binary this allows Democrats to claim
that what we must do is expend trillions
of new dollars on things like extended
unemployment benefits through January
which by the way is fairly a guarantee
that people aren't actually gonna be
able to hire people back one of the
major problems that's been happening
right now is the businesses across
America small businesses are saying to
their own employees guys you know
there's gonna come a point here where we
want you to come back and if you're
young and healthy you should come back
and people are saying why I can get more
on unemployment this is a hole that was
pointed out by Senators Tim Scott and
Marco Rubio and Ben Sasse and they were
saying guys you know are our last cares
cares Act package that included payments
that were greater than people would be
receiving in the absence of a salary
meaning that if you were making 1,200
bucks a month or a twelve hundred bucks
if you're making twelve hundred week
before now you're gonna make more than
that from unemployment so why the hell
would you go back to work Democrats
would like to extend that now so this is
what Nancy Pelosi
is suggesting she's saying look we have
the opportunity to save lives and our
democracy it's the last part that
matters we have the opportunity to save
lives in our democracy means we have the
opportunity to tell you that we are
saving lives by keeping the economy
closed and also it's quote unquote save
democracy by radically reshift ensue
power between the federal government and
individuals these numbers require action
that we've never had to take before
there are those who said let's just
pause so if the families who are
suffering though that hunger doesn't
take a pause the rent doesn't take a
fall as the bills don't take a pause the
hardship of losing a job or tragically
losing a loved one doesn't take a pause
this is an historic challenge and
therefore momentous opportunity for us
to meet the needs of the American people
to save their lives their livelihoods at
our democracy what a pathetic
pathetic human being Nancy Pelosi is
truly this is not an opportunity take a
pause twice in the last month twice she
has quote-unquote taken a pause on major
legislation designed to help out
business and help out individuals she
shut down the passage of the Cara's act
for a full week and then she shut down
the passage of the payroll Protection
Act for a full week wait what the hell
but now it's we got a rush forward we
got a rush forward without a three
trillion dollar wishlist of garbage here
is what is in the Democrats three
trillion dollar-plus of iris relief bill
there's gonna keep spending here we're
going to effectively try modern monetary
theory and find out how it works modern
monetary theory is of course the idiotic
theory that we can continue to spend
money at infinite pace without bearing
any results down the road either in
terms of radically increased taxation or
in terms of inflating the currency which
is great I mean if it's true I guess we
can just magically spend government
money and people will just continue
taking out decks they're idiots
apparently apparently everybody across
the world is a
and if we continue to take out debt then
everybody across the world instead of
investing in other opportunities there
didn't just buy the American the
American debt sure because they because
they feel like it's gonna get paid off
at some point so what exactly is in this
neutral three trillion dollar package
here's what's in it fiscal aid to states
and local governments the Democratic
bill provides more than nine hundred
billion dollars to states local
governments as well as Indian tribes and
territorial governments to help prevent
layoffs of public workers cuts to
services or tax hikes so instead of
forcing states to actually tighten their
belt and look at the union contracts
that they have signed that are garbage
and look at all the pension plans they
sign that are garbage instead the
federal government is gonna bail out all
of the garbage plans blaming it on the
pandemic let's be real about this
California was basically bankrupt before
any of this happened because they signed
garbage pension deals the same thing is
true in Illinois the same thing is true
in New York the state debt of these of
these states was exorbitant like
hundreds of billions of dollars maybe
maybe trillions of dollars in the state
of California before any of this
happened and now the Democrats are
basically using this as an excuse to say
you know we can do we can have state
governors who just sign these really
really rich contracts these ridiculous
contracts with unions that say things
like don't worry guys we're gonna give
you like an eight percent year-on-year
increase in the pension and then we'll
just tell you that if you and that will
invest our pension funds properly and
they will return eight percent that's
what we actually did with CalPERS in
Lausanne in California the union
contracts with CalPERS it basically
suggested that
there was going to be a seven to eight
percent rate of return year-on-year in
the CalPERS fund which is insane no one
does that Warren Buffett doesn't do that
okay so you sign all these bad contracts
and then when there's a crisis you go
you know what we could
we can't pay unemployment because we're
bankrupt because you know we wasted all
our money on stupid garbage and bad
contracts so well it'd be great as if
the feds could fill us in so that's
that's what's in the Democrat bill what
else well they want a second round of
direct payments to individuals making
those benefits more generous than an
earlier round which limited payments for
dependent children to $500 instead it
provides new payments of $1,200 per
family member up to $6,000 for a
household $6,000 for a household that is
a crapload of money so your family of
four and you get $6,000 check in the
mail why would anybody go back to work
seriously like at a certain point we
would like to have a functioning economy
again and by the way they would like to
keep the unemployment benefits extended
by six hundred dollars per week federal
unemployment which supplements the state
unemployment benefits they want that
supplemented through January 2021
okay now cutting it off at the end of
July when the pandemic is supposedly
supposed to wait I'm not even extending
it two more months they won't extend it
to January which is not surprisingly
past the election right they would like
for the unemployment rates to remain
high apparently because people won't go
back to work and that is not just
relieving people who cannot go back to
work if you're talking about this thing
where it directed toward people who
showed some sort of serious illness a
pre-existing thish you have diabetes you
don't want to be back in public as you
got diabetes and this thing is dangerous
you're above the age of 60 and so you
don't want to be back at the workplace
because it's dangerous to you and then
we want to create unemployment benefits
specifically for those people I could I
could get on board with that I can when
I cannot get on board with is the idea
that if you're perfectly healthy and
twenty five years old you should be
receiving endless government benefits
because you don't really believe that
you should go back to work and because
any sort of arbitrary risk calculation
by you means that I'm supposed to pay
your bills and everybody else is
supposed to pay your bills I mean that's
that's insanity also they want to
provide twenty five billion dollars for
the US Postal Service which is expected
to run out of money by the end of
September without congressional aid
because it's losing so much revenue you
know the reason they're losing revenue
it's not because people have stopped
sending mail is because people started
sending the mail the dirty little secret
of the post office is that they lose
money when they don't
and they lose money when they do ship
mail because the postage rates are too
low that's why it's more expensive to
ship via FedEx and it is to ship via the
US Postal Service but instead of raising
rates they just want to bail out the US
Postal Service again also they own pride
one hundred seventy five billion dollars
to States to help renters and homeowners
pay mortgages rent and other housing
costs and avoid default with much of the
money aimed at lower-income people well
again if the states are the ones making
the decisions on when to reopen why
should not the states be actually taking
out the debt to do that why is it the
Texas which is reopening faster to pay
the bills for California which is
reopening more slowly they also want
fifteen billion dollars for state
transportation departments for highway
needs sixteen billion dollars to mass
transit systems hit by the massive
drop-off of ridership and lower income
from fares so in other words we are now
going to pay the New York subway system
for being shut down this is my favorite
one they want to dedicate one hundred
billion dollars to States school
districts and universities said affray
additional costs associated with the
pandemic what additional costs no one's
coming to school you are closed what the
hell are you talking about the teachers
are not in the classroom there are no
what so you're gonna have to explain to
me do we spend more money when the kids
are in school when the kids are out of
school what look what is this what is
this
so naturally the Republicans are about
are bucking at all of this nonsense and
there are also provisions in this bill
that are just obviously stupid they
wanted to vote the House Democrats 1
billion dollars for quote-unquote
modernization of state and local health
inequities data not inequality at
inequities data because every inequality
isn't yet in is in inequity inequality
means that two things are not equal
inequity means the two things are not
fair so any inequality is now in
inequity according to this Democratic
bill they want to support the
modernization of data collection methods
and infrastructure for the purposes of
increasing data related to health
inequities such as racial ethnic
socio-economic sex gender and disability
disparities and they want to provide
guidance technical assistance and
information to grantees under the
section on best practices regarding
culturally competent
accurate and increased data collection
and transmission the hell does that mean
when we do gender studies now with a
billion dollars during a pandemic sounds
great sounds great naturally Mitch
McConnell has objected this means that
he's a very bad man he says our debt is
now the size of the American economy and
you're talking about taking out
trillions of dollars to pay for random
gar
no wait we've already spent about in the
process of spending about 2.8 trillion
dollars we now have a debt the size of
our economy so I have said and the
president has said as well mmm that we
need to take a pause here and take a
look at what we've done see what's
working see what isn't and also begin to
encourage the governors around the
country who have the decision-making
ability to begin to open up the economy
know so that what the Democrats really
want is for lockdown to be the preferred
policy of states and then the bailout to
happen at the federal government level
so they can radically reshift the nation
and quote unquote save democracy that's
that's the actual plan this thing didn't
have to become politically polarized it
is becoming politically polarized when
you just shout lock down infinitely and
then prevent basically presents zero
data to actually support how you are
coming to that conclusion and how you
plan to reopen okay time for some things
that I hate so I have legitimately no
clue why the judge in the Michael Flynn
case is slamming the brakes on the tea
oGH tempted to drop the case they are
now making the case that the judge is
basically delaying all of this saying
that he wants to hear amicus briefs
which is an amazing suggestion it's a
criminal case how do you hear an amicus
brief in a criminal case that's bizarre
according to law and crime calm federal
judge M&G Sullivan stopped at least
temporarily the federal government's
attempt to drop its case against
national security adviser Michael Flynn
Sullivan made the move shortly after
Flynn asked the case against him be
dismissed immediately the judge in a
minute order posted to the Flynn cases
electronic docket said he anticipated
amicus briefs would be filed in the
matter and wanted to give any interested
parties time to participate these so
called friend of the court briefs allow
others who are not party to a case to
submit arguments only for the benefit of
the court Sullivan said it is solely
within the courts discretion to
determine the extent fact and manner of
the participation of amicus parties the
briefs are helpful when the amicus has
unique information or perspective that
can help the court beyond the help that
the lawyers for the parties are able to
provide he also noted reasons why party
should not be allowed to file amicus
briefs Flynn's lawyers have filed the
motion
to prevent an amicus brief from entering
the record in issuing the order Sullivan
quoted a similar men in order from the
judge who oversaw the trial of former
Donald Trump confidant Roger stone he
said as judge Jamie Berman Jackson has
observed while there may be individuals
with an interest in this matter a
criminal proceeding is not a
free-for-all in other words while
Sullivan is giving party some time to
have their voices heard his patience is
not unlimited
he says the court will enter a
scheduling order governing the
submission of amicus curiae briefs
this is bizarro world III I really have
not heard a lot of precedent for the
idea that you're supposed to be able to
submit an amicus brief in a criminal
trial and that's so weird
like in the OJ Simpson case wouldn't it
have been weird if judge Lance Ito had
been like you know what let's hear from
the public now if you've got any sort of
brief on OJ Simpson would love to hear
it we'd love to hear it so odd according
to long crimes Aaron Keller lawyers for
Donald Trump's former national security
adviser Michael Flynn voiced strong
opposition to that order / Flynn's legal
team a group referring to itself as
Watergate prosecutors submitted an email
stating they wish to file amicus curiae
aye briefs the so called friend of the
court briefs helped assist judge in
making decisions
Flynn's attorneys say this Court has
consistently on 24 previous occasions
summarily refused to permit any third
party to inject themselves or their
views into this case Sullivan's decision
resulted in this particular backlash
they said the proposed amicus brief has
no place in this court no rule allows
the filing in the self proclaimed
collection of Watergate prosecutors has
no cognizable special interests
separation of powers fork loses therapy
forecloses their appearance here only
the DOJ and the defense can be heard
accordingly the Watergate prosecutors
attempted filing itself should not be
registered on the docket any attempt by
the group or any individuals to make a
filing in this case must be denied as
how all others have been they say it's
no accident amicus briefs are excluded
in criminal cases a criminal case is a
dispute between the u.s. and a criminal
defendant there's no place for third
parties to meddle in the dispute
certainly not to usurp the role of
governments counsel for the court to
allow another to stand in the place of
the government will be a violation of
the separation of powers they said that
the Watergate prosecutors don't have a
dog in this hunt any more than former
White Water prosecutors or the Clinton
impeachment prosecutors do it said
there's a case of extraordinary national
and international interests there are
countless people including former
prosecutors on both sides of the parties
who would like to express their views
there are many reasons there's no
provision for outsiders to join a
criminal case of course former
prosecutors can submit opinion pieces to
a sword
media outlets but this Court is not a
forum for their alleged special interest
this of course is exactly right this is
so bizarre
I mean seriously I've never heard of
anything really like this maybe there's
precedent for it but I've never heard of
the this idea that I'm allowed to file
an amicus curiae I brief in the middle
of a criminal trial because what I mean
that the case at issue here is whether
the prosecutors are allowed by the way
what's amazing about this truly amazing
is that we've had cases before like
proposition 8 in California where
Attorney General Kamala Harris
she was then the Attorney General of the
state of California became she became
she was a god-awful AG then she became a
god-awful senator one of the things that
she did when she's our god-awful AG is
there's a there's a provision called
proposition 8 in the California
Constitution that sanctioned saying that
that that sanctioned traditional
marriage and said there will be no
same-sex marriage legalized by the state
or approved by the state in the state of
California there is a lawsuit filed
against it right and the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals ended up striking down
prop 8 this thing was gonna go to the
Supreme Court the AG of the state of
California Connell Harris said I'm not
going to defend it in court I'm not
going to defend this in court now that
is an abdication of her duty she's the
AG which means she is supposed to defend
the existing law she is not supposed to
be able to say I don't like this law so
I'm not defending it the Supreme Court
then ruled that because the state of
California was not defending the law
there was no but there was no other
party to step in and other parties were
like well how about this how about we
defend the law and the corners like no
only the state of California can defend
the laws of the state of California
decides not to defend its own law we're
done here so very weird policy
apparently from the federal judiciary
that if you are an AG of a state and the
people of that state passed a referendum
you don't like you can moot that law by
not defending it in court but if you are
the prosecutors in a case and you decide
to drop the case now the judge will hear
amicus curiae AI briefs to hear whether
the case should remain open very very
weird stuff the reality here is that the
the media coverage of this thing has
been overwhelmingly ridiculous
okay Michael Flynn appears to have been
railroaded by a lot of the available
evidence does not mean that Michael
Flynn should be national security
adviser I objected to him as national
security advisor when his first name it
also doesn't mean that he did anything
that rises to the level of the criminal
Liz Cheney the represented from Wyoming
she said it's pretty obvious that
members of the
administration believe they're above the
law they clearly believed they were
above the law
and when you look at what was going on
in terms of unmasking the names of US
officials that were in the classified
documents when you look at what they
were doing after they fired general
Flynn clearly there was some sort of a
vendetta underway
when you look at Jim Comey you know Jim
Comey on tape publicly on video saying
that he knows that he basically violated
the rules violated the practice when he
sent his FBI agents over to interview
general Flynn so I they clearly were
trying to criminalize their political
differences and they need to be
investigated well that I think is
exactly right I think you will see some
investigations of people like James
coming confirmation bias is a hell of a
drug and there are a lot of people who
tend to believe that that the Trump team
was in collusion with Russia because
they could not deal with the fact that
he won the election and so they were
going to bend every rule in order to
confirm they're biased notions as to
what exactly was happening here already
time for should we do a quick thing I
like okay fine we'll do a quick thing I
like so the thing that I like today is
the movie Shawshank Redemption okay so I
know I know it's the thing everybody
likes but I've been rewatching some old
classics and what I found is you know
I've spent a long time and during you
know but really I like watching new
movies I like watching movies I've never
seen I'm finding renewed pleasure in
watching old movies and brie watching
old movies so in the past week or so
I've been watching old movies my wife
and I did a Christopher Nolan binge
right before I kid was born now I'm
going back to some some older movies and
I will discuss one of those tomorrow
which is maybe the greatest movie ever
made or at least the greatest couple of
pairs in movies ever ever made but
Shawshank Redemption is in fact a
fantastic movie it is a great movie it
works on every level it's one of those
movies where well it's one of those TNT
movies right there there's a series of
TNT movies for a while when people used
to get cable where you'd be flipping the
channel and this would be on maybe like
okay I'm gonna watch for three minutes
and two hours later you were still
sitting there watching it and you have
the DVD but you're not gonna pop in the
DVD you're just gonna wait for the
commercials to pass shawshank
redemption' addictive movie here's a
little bit of the trailer for those who
haven't seen it this it's a great movie
and the good news is that by the time
you finish watching it the pandemic will
be over because it's 9 hours long didn't
think much of and the first time I laid
eyes on him
they had a quiet way about it walk talk
that just wasn't normal around here
there are places in the world that
aren't made out of stone there's
something inside they can't touch
[Music]
obviously if you haven't seen it you're
missing out and I'm sure everybody has
seen it it's pretty brutal film but it
is it is a great movie by the way
another great move by Frank Darabont
very underrated Green Mile Green Mile is
also an excellent movie which is worthy
of a watch so what's amazing about this
movie by the way is it's a complete
failure when it first came out at the
box office it really did not do well one
of the reasons is because it has one of
the worst names in the history of film
right it's Shawshank Redemption means
nothing like the title means nothing but
it's one of those movies where because
it hit basic-cable it became a
backlogged hit and now it's according to
IMDB everybody's favorite movie so go
check it out if you have not and enjoy
yourself this evening ok we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow as we enjoy lock-down
infinity plus one you're listening to
the bench Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike foramina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 25 hey everybody
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the American Republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over the Andrew Kleber show
and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]